keeping chemistry alive and attraction
alive and your sex lives Alive is is
important and takes attention what are
the best ways to do that the least sexy
thing is being stressed out all the time
that's not when we're hot if we're
chronically stressed what's happening
are we not giving to ourselves are we
not filling our cup are we not
exercising are we not resting so we have
to take care of our emotional mental
well-being that's very very important
because when we do
we're more energized and when we're
energized we bring that energy to a
relationship and it's sexy like the
hottest thing is seeing the person that
you're into that you're in a
relationship with in their element when
you look at really successful
relationships and and I measure
successful relationships with two people
who really like each other and love each
other they're not perfect but they
really really like each other and and
they still want to have sex with each
other